I find your story particularly
interesting because you were 17 I
believe when when we started there were
six months of auditions I had seen a
production when I was still in high
school and under scholarship because my
parents I was Mexican from Temple City
went to Rosemead high school and I I
went when I was 13 - Eugene Lorentz
American School of Dance
it completely transformed me so I
studied and I studied and I studied and
I studied and I saw a production of West
Side at the Pasadena Playhouse I I'd
never seen anything like that I didn't
understand that I just knew that it was
so real and I went back to mr. lorring
and I said you've got there auditioning
I read about it you've got to get me
there and he said well you know I I
didn't belong to any Union they were
having they had six months of auditions
and Jerry went everywhere in the world
that had ever done a production of West
Side and so he called his agent who
called stall master Lister somehow I
don't know where I got into some
audition and people were lined up
outside of the soundstage and Jerry this
went on you had a ballet combination
intense if you pass that then Tommy
Abbott and Jeffrey Howard Jeffries his
assistants would teach you a combination
maybe show it to you twice and I was
small ethnic so I always had to fight
for center stage otherwise I'd get lost
so you it was this way for six months
then I did three screen tests and I
thought well maybe there's a chance and
after about six months and they were
already casting people I just said I got
to go home and see my mom and just get a
little family love and I got there it
was a Friday and the phone rang and I
knew
this was the call I knew it and I was
scared and I told my mom you gotta
answer this she answered it and she was
very uh ha mmhmm yeah okay yes and then
okay thank you and she hung up and by
now I'm like what did they say and she
said well they said that you're to be at
Monday morning at 10 o'clock
Sam golden studios and congratulations I
was crazy I jumped up I know my whole
block must have heard me screaming and
yelling and great this is the first
thing that had ever happened to anybody
in my family and then the unthinkable
happened
I fell to my knees with a horrible
abdominal pain I didn't know where it
came from my mother somehow I don't even
remember she was actually managed to get
me into the back seat of the car I said
where are we going and she said to the
hospital that was a Friday they said I
had gotten there just in time before my
appendix were gonna burst they operated
send me home Saturday and then Sunday
and my mom called Howard and them and
said you know Maria had to have this
operation I didn't know this until
Howard called Sunday and Jerry needed to
know if I needed to be replaced and I
begged my mother factor no I couldn't no
no I will be there and she says money oh
you can't you're barely able to walk I
will be there I will be there so she
said okay I'll have her there at 10
o'clock and that next morning that
Monday morning she put that horrible
white adhesive tape it was it was so
we're talking fifty years ago and it
just she should've wrapped me in it and
I took my dad's bag my point she was my
character shoes my jazz shoes and a
black sweater that made me it was my
Linus blanket and I said okay put that
in there
and she dropped me off at Sam golden and
I had to make sure I didn't want anybody
to know I didn't know anybody you know
really that closely and all these people
seem to belong I mean all the New York
dancers I remember seeing Russ he was so
confident and all these dancers we took
a ballet class and I thought you know
that's so-and-so her point work it's and
all that great and I can do this
and her extension isn't all that great
and okay we think this is all right so
anyway we we started rehearsing and
doing you know ballet work and whatever
and I could just feel everything and you
just have two dancers you just had to
get into another zone and I managed to
do that I just left and danced and then
Jerry came onto the set and something
happened I thought everybody was dancing
full-out they weren't and I saw all of a
sudden the the leaps were bigger and the
jetties were bigger and the splits were
bigger and I'm thinking and Jerry was
looking trying to find who's gonna be
the weak one who's good and I said it's
not gonna be me I can tell you now it's
not all the time that I got to get here
and we danced and we danced and we
danced and I did over it just did it
over and over and over I don't even
remember I was just in another
atmosphere and then I noticed that there
was blood on the floor and I thought oh
my god did anybody see that
I grabbed my black sweater I wrapped it
around me and Howard came to me very
quietly and his he had this great droll
about he talked he said Maria he said
you need to go see the doctor and I said
I'll do it on my lunch hour not now
because I don't want to miss anything
that mr. Robbins is going to say so got
through it
yes I went to the medon medical doctor
and he said yeah
you're gonna have to have new stitches
my mother picked me home took me home
and she said we got to get it done a
nicer mama I got through the grace of
God he honored me I had victory and
that's what doing this movie was this
high I graduated in three years instead
of four so that I could get on with my
career my parents didn't have money so I
had to apply for a scholarship so it was
doable and that first day was the
beginning of a whole new journey and it
was I got through it
and I got strapped and yes once again
and once again and once again and
Westside became my family more than even
my own immediate family and we're still
together we've been together through
life death birth divorce drugs
everything and we are still here
and I for me the victory of doing
Westside is if you have the desire and
we call it ganas in Spanish if you
haven't got us in the will you can do
anything it doesn't matter your color
your size your race if you have a will
then you just give it to God and say do
it I'll do it I can do this I can do
this